In this video, we will do
some basic data analysis.
All that I've done
since our previous video
is clear the console, but R
still has all the information
stored.
In fact, if we use the
Up Arrow on our keyboard,
we retrieve the last
command we typed,
which was the summary
of the USDA data frame.
And as a quick reminder, at
the end of our last video,
we realized that the
maximum level of Sodium
was 38,758 milligrams,
which is very high.
We would like to see which
food this corresponds to.
Well, to check the values of
sodium levels in the foods
within the data set, we
can type USDA$Sodium.
This gives us a series
of numbers associated
with the amount of sodium in
all the foods in our data set.
Remember from the lecture
that this is called a vector,
and it is associated
with the variable Sodium.
For instance, the sodium
level of the last food
in our data set
is 68 milligrams.
Now, to find which food has
the highest level of sodium,
we can simply use the
function which.max, which
takes as an input
the Sodium vector,
and it gives us the index of
the food with the highest sodium
level.
In this case, the 265th
food in our data set
has the maximum sodium content.
Now to know which
food that is, we
need to take a look at
the vector corresponding
to the text description
of the foods.
However, I cannot remember the
exact name of that variable
on top of my head to be
able to call it in R.
But we can use the
function names,
which takes as an input the
USDA data frame and gives us
the exact names of all the
variables as stored in the USDA
data frame.
And now we know that the name
of the variable we're looking at
is Description.
So now, to get the
name of the 265th food,
we simply need to ask R
to pick the 265th element
from the vector Description.
So, using our dollar notation
to call the Description vector
and then the square brackets
around the index 265,
and the winner is table salt!
Well, having 38,758 milligrams
of sodium in 100 grams of table
salt sort of makes
sense, but none of us
would eat 100 grams of
salt in one sitting.
So it might be more
interesting to find
out which foods, for
instance, contain more than,
say, 10,000
milligrams of sodium.
To do so, we can create
a new data frame,
and let's call it HighSodium.
And this is going to be a
subset of our original data
frame, USDA, with
only the foods that
have sodium content
that exceeds 10,000.
And now we created
this new data frame,
and to see how many foods there
exist in this new data frame,
we need to see how many
observations this data
frame has.
And this can be done by using
the function nrow, which
computes the number of rows
in the data frame HighSodium.
And then we obtain 10
foods with sodium levels
above 10,000 milligrams.
Since there are not many, we can
output the names of these foods
by looking at their
Description vector.
But this time, the
Description vector
is not associated with
the USDA data frame
but with the
HighSodium data frame.
So HighSodium$Description,
and now pressing Enter,
we obtain the names
of these 10 foods.
So definitely table
salt is one of them.
We also have dry soup,
gravy, some leavening agents,
but I thought caviar is well
known to be among the top 10
foods with highest
levels of sodium.
But it doesn't
appear in this list.
Let's find how much sodium
it has in 100 grams.
Now, obviously, this task
would have been very easy
if we knew the index of
caviar in our data set,
and we simply feed it
into the vector Sodium.
However, we need to get
the index of caviar,
and to do this, we
need to track down
the word caviar in
the text description.
To do this, we can
use the match function
and ask R to dig the word caviar
in the description vector.
So USDA$Description.
And now pressing Enter,
we obtain that caviar is
the 4,154th food
in our data set.
So now finding the sodium level
of caviar is a piece of cake.
We just type USDA$Sodium and,
using the square brackets with
the index 4,154, ask R to pick
the sodium level of caviar
for us.
And this is 1,500 milligrams.
Now, to find a level of sodium
in caviar, we used two steps,
but we can actually lump
them all in one single step.
So let's use the Up
Arrow twice to go back
to the match function, and we
know that this match function
gives us an index that then
should be fed into the Sodium
vector using square brackets.
So let's enclose it
in square brackets,
and then at the beginning
we're going to just write
USDA$Sodium.
And, again, of
course, this gives us
1,500 milligrams of sodium
in 100 grams of caviar.
Now, the value 1,500
milligrams seems
to be very small compared to
10,000 milligrams or 38,000
milligrams, which are the values
that we worked with so far
with respect to sodium levels.
But this doesn't seem
to be a fair comparison.
Maybe the best way to figure
out how big this value is,
is by comparing it to the mean
and the standard deviation
of the sodium levels
across the data set.
To find the mean, we know
that this information
is given to us using
the summary function.
So let's use the summary
function, and this time,
give it the input
the Sodium vector
instead of the whole
USDA data frame.
And we can see that the mean
sodium value is 322 milligrams.
However, the summary
function does not
give us standard
deviation information,
but we can do this using
the function sd, which
stands for standard deviation.
Give it as an input
the Sodium vector,
and, oh, we obtain
non-available.
Well we got NA because
we forgot to remove
the non-available
entries before computing
our statistical measure.
So let's use the Up Arrow to go
back to the standard deviation
function, and now we have to
explicitly tell R to remove
these non-available entries
by typing na.rm=TRUE.
And now the standard
deviation is 1,045 milligrams.
Note that, if we sum the mean
and the standard deviation,
we obtain around 1,400
milligrams, which
is still smaller than
the amount of sodium
in 100 grams of caviar.
Well, this means that caviar
is pretty rich in sodium
compared to most of the
foods in our data set.
Now that we know how to do a
basic analysis of our data,
let's look at the plotting
functionality in R
in our next video.